then he went Donald Trump you know
Donald Trump I love Donald Trump but no
more dropped by the drop boxes are just
so bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
apologic and cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth essential
law and he voted for
amnesty as you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations than Jesse
James Billy that could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come
once said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the bronze star and the
combat infantry and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
people but it's not I mean for some
reason it's just not great anymore if
you care about Law and Order look Law
and Order in normal times roughly 40
percent of fresh vegetables at about 40
percent China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and swept in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous it's really an anonymous
gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business the teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children without
parent of himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you hurt them and you know them well
ladies and gentlemen do not adjust your
television it is real
his real first time
's being indicted and will face criminal
charges this is all just such great
views such great news I was proven even
more right than I would have ever
imagined because apparently you know
there is actually igniting my father so
maybe I was wrong maybe prayer does work
[Music]
right communist level
thank you
great communist level yet
communist level
communist level great Orange
God
forbid Donny boy God forbid Donny boy
great orange leader Dear God
communist level this is
communist
like it
is communist level
communist level
you gotta get them on patch
great to be here you gotta get them on
here
[Music]
Socialism or no
you like the fact that us has liked more
today
[Music]
seriously
seriously keep going what are you
talking about keep going what are you
talking about that's insane
all right folks we've gotta cut it where
are my Graphics there they are we've got
to cut it because there is too much news
the failed former once indicted twice
impeached president Donald Trump has
been indicted did again this time
federal charges I was pulled out of the
shower for this news I with wet hair and
my contacts out barreled through the
extremely low Quality Air due to the
Canadian wildfires
to come here to tell you today
with peace and love
that the former president has been
indicated excuse me indicted for a
second time
this could be the second of three
this could be the second of four and it
could potentially be the second of five
indictments I'm soaking wet already from
the shower
and we are going to review everything
everything that is going on
czechoseki wrongly reporting via Super
Chat that the indictment was for all the
fast food Trump brought to the White
House not true
not true let's talk about what we know
so far it is starting to build at
Mar-A-Lago Trump will be arraigned folks
he's getting arrested again he's getting
arrested again
and maybe we'll get a mug shot maybe
they'll cuff him up
on Tuesday at 3 P.M Eastern Time noon
Pacific I'm clearing my schedule for
probably for the next month or so I'm
going to take the whole month off but
I'll cover the Tuesday thing just
because it's going to be so crazy and I
hope you'll be with us for it let's see
what we know so far
Trump indicated on seven criminal counts
in the classified documents case this
doesn't even touch the riotous
Insurrection okay this is just the
documents former they really should say
failed former president but okay former
president Donald Trump has been indicted
in federal court
in connection with his retention of
classified government documents after
leaving the White House Trump himself
disclosed the indictments in a series of
posts oh hold on I need to make sure I
have my glitches
uh where is my truth
oh God what is happening I'm so on his
truth social media site truth essential
he also said he has been summoned to
appear in court in Miami on Tuesday he
is currently seeking the 2024 Republican
Presidential nomination an FBI raid of
his Mar-A-Lago residence last summer
found hundreds of classified records
let's go right to Troth Central
here is Donald Trump issuing a statement
in all caps I am an innocent man the
Biden Administration is totally corrupt
no evidence Biden has anything to do
with this this election interference and
a continuation of the greatest Witch
Hunt of all time make America great
again let's hear from it from the
horse's mouth itself
very sadly We're a nation of decline
and yet they go after a popular
president a president that got more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country but eight million
fewer votes than the winner Joseph R
Biden Jr by far
ended much better the second time in the
election than
the first I did way better I'm I'm
likely to I'm likely to be arrested four
times but I did way better than sleepy
Joe
and they go after him on a boxer's house
just like the Russia Russia Russia hoax
and all of the others this has been
going on for seven years and they can't
stop right because it's election
interference at the highest level
there's never been anything like what's
happened I'm an innocent man I'm an
innocent person Trump proclaiming his
innocence
not particularly convincingly I must say
they had the Mueller hoax the Mueller
report and that came out no collusion
after two and a half years that was set
up by Hillary Clinton and Democrats no
evidence this is what they do this is
what they
do so well if they would devote their
energies to honesty and integrity would
be a lot better for our country they
could do a lot better they could do a
lot of great things none of these are
legal arguments by the way which Trump
will now have to pay someone to make I
guess but when you look at what's
happened to our country in the last
three years
strong military that wasn't woke we were
doing so well we were respected all over
them all right so basically the the same
adject trash let's see what Trump had to
say here is his announcement page one
the corrupt Biden Administration has
informed my attorneys that I have been
indicted seemingly over the boxes hoax
even though Joe Biden has eighteen
hundred and fifty capital B boxes at the
University of Delaware additional
capital B boxes in Chinatown DC with
even more capital B boxes at the
University of Pennsylvania and documents
strewn all over his garage floor where
he Parks his Corvette and which is quote
secured by only a garage door that is
paper thin and open much of the time
page two I have been summoned to appear
at the federal courthouse in Miami
Tuesday 3 P.M I never thought it
possible that such a thing could happen
to a former president of the United
States who received far more votes than
any sitting president in the capital H
history of our Capital C country and is
currently leading by far all capital c
candidates both Democrat and Republican
in capital P polls of the 2024
presidential election caps lock and Gage
I am an innocent man
page three this is indeed a dark day for
the United States of America we are a
Capital C country in serious and Rapid
capital D decline but together we will
make America great again
um wild wild wild stuff super chats are
dumping in elements of indictments just
wanted to show support wish I could
afford to do more great to see you so
great to see you here big thank you to
Jason sigmaier for gifting a
subscription on the David pakman show
website and welcome to all of our new
twitch Prime subscribers Zuzu pebbled
Pebbles and Mr vister as well as New
Hampshire fog Billy Carpenter irie man
uh fake artifacts and Sam the sleaze bag
dirt nap it's it's all crazy folks we'll
open phone lines and get your thoughts
if we get to a hundred new members but
there is so much to discuss
let's continue here with the CNBC report
what do we know about charges not much
the nature of the latest charges against
Trump are not public as the indictment
is sealed for now the New York Times
citing people familiar with with the
matter I assume they mean reported that
the charges include quote willfully
retaining National Defense secrets in
violation of the Espionage Act
Trump is getting charged under the
Espionage Act making false statements in
an obstruction of justice conspiracy wow
Trump is the only U.S president ever to
be criminally charged remember that
there are the two stories of presidents
who were
um I guess it was like arrested on some
like one was a traffic infraction or
something and then we're talking about
something very different this is
definitely the only time this has
happened to a former president in this
way where we're talking about charges
arraignment and everything that we are
seeing and it is going to be an
incredible week and I hope that you will
be here uh with us in a video statement
Thursday Trump called the charges
election interference at the highest
level no evidence of that of course
we already went through the Troth
Central posts we know that agents found
hundreds of documents marked classified
at Trump's house
uh Biden griped I'm Trump gripe that
Biden hasn't been arrested Biden uh
Trump really seems to want other
presidents to be arrested for Trump's
crimes let's listen to what is happening
on Newsmax the copium is heavy I believe
this is Matt schlapp who has been of
course accused of sexual assault he runs
um what's the thing called the CPAC
let's listen on the charges and then
when he became the president they did
everything they could to hobble him and
we know everything about the Mueller
investigation the special counsel they
went through every document I've heard
enough total standard Trump apologia
nothing nothing too uh compelling really
for me let's uh continue with super
chats Andrew says David Sir with tears
in my eyes I tell you I was live with
you January 6th and here for this good
days as the Trump trash machine that is
the Banana Republican party increasing
is shredding itself
Brad says does Trump realize that
eighteen thousand
12x10x8 boxes would take up roughly 1.4
million square feet of course he doesn't
yeah Biden has basically like an Amazon
warehouse in order to store all those
documents or something Bernie says
brother Dave will John old J Trump will
plead guilty from the standpoint of not
guilty where's my John old president
Donald Trump J Trump absolutely
absolutely here is Sebastian Gorka no
doubt running interference for Trump
inflation war in Europe what you know no
baby formula on the shelves for
Americans there's no way you can
reasonably win this next election wow so
I guess Gorka is saying Biden has no
shot because the economy is so bad of
course the baby formula issues have been
resolved and also we went through the
economic situation metric by Metric on
Monday and the economy is fine I mean
there could be a recession coming that's
always the case but the economy is
essentially fine at this point in time
let's see what we have happening over on
Fox News I'm curious whether they're
molding viewed over documents that's
governed exclusively by a civil statute
the presidential records act that act
means anything created during a
presidency whether it's classified or
not
can be maintained by a former president
period but instead of seeking an
injunction let's say or production of
Records in a civil court let a judge
hash it out Garland chose to bastardize
the law by writing Trump's home and then
seeking an indictment today and it
didn't matter that Trump was following
the very same standard isn't this great
by the Department of Justice itself a
decade ago in the Bill Clinton case who
kept classified documents that was a
standard endorsed by a federal court in
Washington the president can keep what
he wants but Garland didn't like that
and he doesn't care about the law so he
abandoned his own precedent because it's
Donald Trump going to have time to get
all of the legal analyzes but there's
already a number of lies and distortions
here from Fox news's Greg Jarrett
including that it was wrong and
unprovoked to raid Trump's house they
gave Trump months to return the
documents months to return the documents
and he didn't do it and then they went
to get them because I don't think he
would have supported charges for Hillary
or Joe Biden either would you
no I don't think we should be
criminalizing these decisions to take
either accidentally or deliberately
material home I believe that every
single president all of these
indictments are just trumped up even
though they of course pre uh many of
them pre-exist the Biden Administration
they're for unrelated wrongdoing it's
all crazy it's all crazy thanks to
guitar goddess for gifting 10
subscriptions on Twitch and also thanks
to the couple of additional folks who
just signed up there and a huge thank
you
to Cheryl white as well as Aiden Myers
for signing up on my website folks if
there has ever been a day
ever
to support Independent Media I believe
that it is today the fire hose of
misinformation is about to explode
we have one of the most important
presidential elections certainly that
I've ever covered coming up
and the president
is going to uh run for reelection
on the basis of an economy that while it
looks fine by the metrics the right is
saying everything's terrible and the sky
is falling there has never been a time
at which the misinformation has been
fought as this I invite you to grab a
membership on my website joinpakman.com
we because Trump's been indicted you can
use the coupon code indicted to get a
discount you can use the coupon code
indicated to get an even bigger discount
that's the crazy thing and as always we
are pushing our way
to 2 million YouTube subscribers and if
you are here right now I would love it
if you hit that subscribe button on
YouTube because it is going to be a wild
wild year and a half that I can assure
you let's continue to monitor the copium
on Fox News as we also hear from people
in the audience I want to say thanks to
Andrew for gifting five subscriptions
via YouTube Bay photo says is there
another potential situation where de
Sanctus little Rhonda Rob could be put
into a position where he has to
extradite Trump well in theory but Trump
has to go to Florida to face these
charges not leave Florida to go
elsewhere go to Florida
so um at least not right now
Liz says watching the Twitter response
from the far right is literally
terrifying there isn't a more divided
country on earth watching from South
Africa and shaking my head yeah it is uh
it is wild what's going on speaking of
Twitter let's just see some of the stuff
that is going on here uh
let's see what we've got Hillary of
course laughing big time at what's going
on
Marjorie Taylor green tweeting agit
trash as is often the case
we already looked at the Trump
statements
Tim Scott as we've all been anxiously
waiting to hear what presidential
candidate Tim Scott would say about
Trump being indicted again let's listen
the headlines this morning are about an
imminent indictment of the former
president uh what is your reaction to
those reports
you know one of the things I'd say is
that I want uh hey it's a serious
serious challenge for the president
former president B I'd say I still
believe that the determining factor for
the 2024 election should be the voters I
think it is very very dangerous to see
and or feel like the Department of
Justice is being weaponized of course it
might feel that way to Tim Scott but it
happens not to be backed by any evidence
whatsoever
um
here is Marco Rubio weighing in there is
no limit to what these people will do to
protect their power and destroy those
who threaten it even if it means ripping
our country apart and shredding public
faith in the institutions that hold our
Republic together I want to now declare
a very very important
thing for lack of a better term
you are going to hear over the next
minutes and hours and days and certainly
weeks what we already started hearing
after Trump was arrested the first time
and that is going to be that this shows
that there is something not working in
this country that Trump being indicted
shows us that something is wrong that
our institutions aren't working in
reality what these indictments tell us
when a guy who so obviously
uh at least plausibly committed so many
crimes
and then that person gets indicted it
tells us no one is above the law it is a
good thing to see that no one is above
the law we do have two Justice systems
in the United States the one for the
wealthy and the elites and the one for
everybody else and we know all too often
how that works out to see that Donald
Trump is not above the law at least so
far as being charged and then we'll see
what happens actually tells us something
is working don't let these people Lead
You astray on that
um let's look at a couple of other
uh super chats and then we'll get back
to that Grant says first saw you on Lex
Friedman now I'm hooked been a long time
Destiny viewer truly hope to see you in
Destiny talk again sometime soon yeah
I'm up for talking to Destiny anytime I
guess the issue is that Destiny's banned
from twitch so I can't uh I can't have
them on that's my understanding of
what's going on big thank you to Lisa
Rader Stephen Brown and Conor harsh for
signing up at joinpakman.com folks if
you're new here or if you're not
today's the day to sign up on my website
if we get to 100 we'll open phone lines
we'll hear people's thoughts about
what's going on with the indictment
brass tax says can we talk about how
bidens not Joe Biden made money from
foreign sources I hear the Russian asset
who made the claim is a really reliable
source I don't know if that's satire to
be totally honest I'm not sure
Mart says I know I've said it before but
today more than ever your work is so
important keep it up thanks Mark I
appreciate that
Mr Scott says I've almost filled a row
on my trump criminal charges Edition
bingo card just need one more
obstruction of justice in this round is
mine Mr Scott I think you're going to
win it I think you're going to get it
Tim says sir I have tears in my eyes
what a great day for this country
accountability do not let the right
trick you into thinking that these
indictments are evidence that something
is not working these indictments are
evidence that maybe something is working
a little bit in the country a little bit
in the country
uh let's continue seeing what our
various uh right-wing friends and
lunatics are
um saying on Twitter
Trump previously was raising money based
on not being indicted now he's raising
money on being indicted that's
interesting Ronnie Jackson is calling it
a Witch Hunt yoga Ronnie Jackson's a
lunatic
uh
Stephen Miller I believe history will
record today as the day we ceased to be
a Democratic Republic I'm not big on
predictions but I don't think so for
president Trump who has seen him up
close and personal on what a heart he
has for this country let me also say
that I believe history will record today
is the day that we cease to
a Democratic Republic and we became a
people ruled by an unelected government
bureaucracy I disagree
I disagree completely I don't think that
that is at all at all at all at all what
we have learned from today if you care
about
I care about law Otto
umbrella life insurance I care about all
of it okay and I don't believe that that
is what we are going to take away from
today Trump fundraising off of the
indictment saying no matter how
viciously they attack me I will never
ever surrender our country to the
radical left
uh turning that one around pretty
quickly
you will notice that Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton have not been indicted
Obama
um let's see what else we have here
a lot a lot of nonsense quite frankly
president rep Congressman Andy Biggs
says president Trump is indicted on the
day we unveiled significant findings
related to Joe Biden's corruption makes
you wonder I hate to break it to Andy
Biggs they didn't reveal significant
findings and also no one's paying
attention to that no one's paying
attention to what Andy Biggs is doing
um
Nancy mace says she's not a shill but
this is all so unfair to Trump and when
you look at the standard that he has
it's a double standard it's a it's a
second tier a double standard of Justice
in this country and what the American
people want they want everybody to be
treated the same and you know Donald
Trump's no fan of mine he primaried me
last year so I'm not a shill but I see
this and I see how unfair it's been and
uh you know I just can't believe this is
happening and I said this two days ago
uh Harris I said that this was going to
happen on the day that we either and
that we either held in contempt
Christopher Ray with the FBI or we got
access to those documents you were right
I predicted it it came true you just
this is the banana banana republic I
just cannot believe that this is what's
actually happening he's trying the the
new not Nest not that new but the line
from Republicans now is you can tell
this country sucks because Trump isn't
above the law that's essentially the
argument that they're making big thank
you
to uh
uh Nathan Rylander Denise Miller Connor
Allen Jennifer Holland and Michelle
Jackson putting us at 50 out of a
hundred signing up at joinpakman.com
really appreciate that let's continue we
looked at the Stephen Miller clip
um
Stephen Miller hopes everybody in the
Republican party coalesces around Trump
for his box politically
well I sure hope that that's exactly
what happens that the whole of the
Republican Party the whole of the
conservative movement and the whole of
the country that cares about the rule of
law coalesces around president Trump in
this moment if you care about the rule
of law don't you have to look at this
and say hey this is due process
investigation leads to evidence evidence
presented to a grand jury grand jury
says indict and now Trump is going to
get his day in court that's the due
process that these right-wingers claim
to want
that they claim to want
and yet and yet and yet
now they complain
um let's take a look and see what is
happening
um over on NBC News Ed said rally so
that's what these videos are designed
for
um and look
he sounds like a this is what I have
just been curious about this whole time
even if voters start to impact him he
does not like sound like a guy who's
ever going to quit this race and he's
ever going to stop running and I don't
know how the Republican party is going
to deal with him or figure out how to
get rid of him if he is somehow uh
potentially headed for a guilty burden
you know today I interviewed former
Republican strategist uh Steve Schmidt
and I told him it seems like a lot of
the non-trump candidates other than
Chris Christie are basically waiting
around for Trump to be pulled off the
campaign Trail because he has too many
indictments against him the problem is
it can't work for all of them they're
not all going to benefit from that and
what Steve Schmidt said is it's not
actually going to work for any of them
that's sort of the argument that Chuck
Todd seems to be making here
um
let's see what's going on on Newsmax and
did much better the second time in the
election than
the first
and they go after him on a Box's hoax
just like the Russia Russia Russia all
right we already uh we already looked at
that earlier
[Music]
um
so I don't think we need to look at it
again J minty fresh says via Super Chat
hey David how are you I saw Trump was
indicted along with the fact that Pat
Robertson passed during pride month how
ironic it is an odd thing it really is
100 Savages says hey David glad to see
that law and auto has prevailed God
bless the United slates uh couldn't have
said it better myself and czechoseki
says Trump was federally indicted but
when is he going to be federally
indicated I wish I knew czechoseki I
wish I knew for people who don't know
chakaseki is the resident radiologist at
the David packman show
um if I had to say
the David pakman show from the
standpoint of medical now I'm talking
strictly medical we are heaviest in
terms of our audience
on neurologists
cardiologists
and maybe Radiologists those may be the
three most represented Medical
Specialties in uh among the David Pacman
show audience at least at least that I
know at least that I'm aware of Music
Addict says David so does this mean
Trump's health care plan is on hold you
know guys
I'm starting to think we may not get
Trump's health care plan in two weeks
that may not happen particularly because
of this latest indictment Bernie says
police officers came up to me big strong
guys they came up to me tears in their
eyes and they said sir you're under
arrest very much well said very very
much well said all right let's listen to
a little bit of how Fox News is running
interference expected to enter a not
guilty plea or a representative of him
will do that for the judge it is also
important to note that the president is
not just facing this circumstance by the
Biden doj he is also facing an
indictment in the state of New York
there is also an ongoing investigation
in the state of Georgia as well and so
this could be a political Death By A
Thousand Cuts or this will be the one
thing that really girds the former
president and his supporters it might
gird his loins and that would be a sight
to see unionized Cracker Barrel says via
Super Chat David I'm worried about the
arresting officers last time Trump said
they were holding back tears this may be
too much for them I do believe
that this time around in Miami on
Tuesday
um
I do believe that the officers will cry
I do think so I think that that is going
to be a a really tough day for them
quite frankly thanks to Robert Ferreira
for signing up at joinpakman.com if
you're just joining us we're at 51 if we
get to 100 we'll open the phone lines
wide open and we'll let all of you weigh
in on these these latest charges Jacob
says but David Trump is still the
president he'll be installed any day now
by the military and the mega Heroes
you'll see yeah guys why can't you just
understand
Trump won in 2020 but they stole it from
him and put Biden in but Trump is really
still the president because he's
controlling the military just not the
woke generals who have gone totally
critical race Theory but meanwhile it's
uh uh there's a Kennedy who has run with
Trump and they really control the whole
thing
right
something along those lines and also
somehow even though Trump is still
president now he can run again even
though you actually can only serve two
terms it's all very weird very very
weird they photo asks do you think Trump
will try and ban men from women's
prisons now and we will men men I'm
gonna opt out
on that particular question
thanks to Mad Max for the twitch Prime
subscription you're number 52. I've got
to hear Mark Levin's reaction to this
let's see he's a total Trump brown-noser
be anage Act of 1917 was passed under
Woodrow Wilson another corrupt president
Woodrow Wilson used it to go after his
adversaries and they imprisoned 2 000
people
so I suppose over there at the
department of Injustice and this clown
prosecutor spent a lot of time at the
hag they probably figured these laws
could be used to try and entrap Trump
all these obstruction issues that they
claim were the former attorney general
you know Mark Levin is trustworthy
because he's holding his glasses the
formers coming on talking about
obstruction they have them on
obstruction there'd be no obstruction
issue of any kind not even in anybody's
imagination had they not criminalized
this case this is a document case I
would go further the only reason
anything is a crime is because they've
criminalized it apply that to any charge
you want guys do you do you do the
people I know the people on YouTube get
it do the people on Twitch realize that
if you didn't make it a crime
it wouldn't be a crime and then that's
it that's it it's just totally unfair
the American people this is a guy that's
got documents from the time he was in
the U.S Senate for God's sakes in his
garage I don't want to hear from the
legal analysts the technicalities about
false statements and obstruction there
should never have been a criminal case
oh my goodness willful retention of
documents well what's the unwillful
retention of documents mean they're
throwing all these process crimes and
all these crimes that grow out of the
criminal investigation against Trump
what did he do with the documents I got
to get popcorn for this no that's why we
have an Espionage Act not to trick of a
president what did he do did he burn
them all no the government has all the
documents back so there is no violation
of the presidential records act at this
point but they throw the book at them
they go after his attorneys they make
them test fi they're attorneys under the
crime fraud exemption to attorney-client
privilege that means he didn't have due
process his own lawyers were being
subjected to interrogations and they had
hundreds of in a person people
testifying in front of grand juries
thousands of collections of documents
for what
For What and they indict him today they
indict them today in Miami all of a
sudden it's in Miami all of a sudden we
have a Florida grand jury because the
in Washington figured out that
there are venue issues that could lose
him his case this guy this prosecutor he
lost eight to zero in the U.S Supreme
Court when they overturned the
conviction of the former Governor
Levin's on fire Levin whoever he says
attitude and expanded it a jury in North
Carolina wouldn't convict John Edwards
because this jerk took a campaign
statute and expanded it and he's taken
this case and he's undermining the
country and he's interfering with a
presidential election and let me be
clear as Jared said the Attorney General
of the United States made this final
decision this is not the independent
Council statute this is a special
counsel of appointed by the Attorney
General under a Department of Justice
regulation this attorney general who
pretends he's Helen Keller he made the
decision to indict the former president
and they made the decision to interfere
in this election you want to this is
really nuts this is an Insurrection and
that's exactly what's going on here let
me go on Joe Biden is the crookedest
crook that's ever been in the Oval
Office everywhere we looked as a
predicate for a special counsel they
won't appoint a special counsel even
though it's compelled under the law in
which they appointed this special
counsel and you're not supposed to
appoint a special counsel against your
political opponent you're supposed to
appoint one in the case of Biden 20
shell corporations 10 million dollars
coming from the Communist Chinese
military should we keep going just to
see how long this is going to go he
looks like he's going to blow a gasket
endless meetings endless meetings with
with bidens uh with Hunter Biden's
business partners Bob olinsky who ties
Joe Biden to the crimes the bobolinsky
testimony was bogus ten percent wasn't
even testimony hey well then where's the
money he's asking us come and Catch Me
If You Can the idea that this man is
isn't under a criminal investigation and
that they criminalize the damn document
case to go after Donald Trump is
sickening and I would say this to our
fellow Americans don't be Bamboozled by
these cable channels and these fools who
come on and tell you well he's not above
the law are you kidding me Democrat
attorney general in New York Democrat
prosecutor in Manhattan Democrat
prosecutor in Atlanta Democrat attorney
general in Washington D.C what do you
mean he's not above the law there is no
law what's going on here is is a
disgusting disgrace how much longer
could this guy go it is war on the
Republican party and it is a war on a
republic the radical left is doing what
the
does while they cover up for Biden the
way they cover it up for Hillary if
Donald Trump is to be charged like this
Hillary Clinton should have been charged
with 10 000 counts of obstruction
because that's so many emails she
destroyed and five counts of destroying
cell phones because that's how many cell
phones they destroyed I'm done and I'm
sick of it
what you said you know Mark many years
ago you said to me and you said in one
of your books we're in a
post-constitutional America and what
you're describing here when you said
they are the ones that all right it's so
I think that's probably enough okay uh
let's see what else is on people's minds
via Super Chat Dex he says Pat Robertson
hatefulness gone voter Rights Act upheld
Trump indicted who knew this random
Thursday would be super
Paul says what is Paul Allen's
indictment look like
uh
uh I don't even remember who Paul Allen
is
American business person
Paul Allen
uh some rich dude I don't even I don't
even know which billionaire that is I'm
sorry oh American Psycho reference okay
uh let's see what else we got sorry I
dropped the ball on that one Air Force
says drain the pool very very important
huge thank you to George McGuire and
Marjorie Milner who just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com if you're just
joining us Donald Trump has been
indicted a second time he will face at
least seven counts he will be in court
Tuesday at 3 P.M in Miami as far as we
know unless he is somehow able not to
have to be there and send only a lawyer
a representative incredible stuff
incredible stuff that is going on thank
you to Tiny sir Jen for gifting five
subscriptions on Twitch and thanks to a
few other people who also signed up
let's see what is happening over on NBC
news here Trump's lawyers say he has
been indicted at an event there so you
were left with this split screen where
you saw the president delivering his
remarks doing his job as president
meanwhile you saw former president Trump
on a Tarmac arriving in New York City it
was a stunning split screen and one that
I think the White House is plenty
satisfied with and it's very likely to
as you will see wall-to-wall coverage of
this tomorrow there will be a not so
December split screen with headlines all
about Donald Trump and this indictment
and President Biden is scheduled to
travel to North Carolina tomorrow he's
delivering remarks on the economy he's
scheduled to visit with troops at Fort
Liberty what was formerly all right so
it'll certainly be a contrast we've come
become accustomed to I think we can say
for sure let's check in a little bit on
what Sebastian Gorka is saying about
this on Newsmax up on Twitter it's from
the Federal Register it's two pages long
it's dated January the 19th the day that
the president was preparing to leave the
white house before the inauguration of
Joe Biden and this document it's a page
and a half it's very brief states that I
president Trump
declassify every dog documents
pertaining to the Russia hoax and
operation Crossfire hurricane it's in
the federal record it has the
president's signature whilst he was
still president
how are they going to bring a case
against him regarding any documents if
they are Declassified Mike help me out
of course if that were true you wouldn't
have a recording where Trump says in
July after leaving office I have
classified documents here that I can't
show you
keep white how on Earth could both of
those things be true questions like
President Clinton did when he took eight
years of audio recordings of his
presidency highly classified audio
recordings including discussions with
foreign leaders that he put in his sock
drawer in an Obama judge in 2012
correctly held that the mere fact that a
president took his presidential records
when he leaves office deems them
personal under the presidential records
act and it doesn't matter whether
they're classified and that's the issue
that's the whole problem with what Biden
is doing here the garlands uh the Biden
justice department attorney general Mary
Collins are trying to charge under the
Espionage Act that does not apply to a
president or former president's handling
of his presidential records if you
believe these right Wingers
everything that's happening to Trump is
just so unfair
nobody who is making prosecutorial
decisions has any idea
how the law works and now we've got
Jonathan Turley who I'm sure is going to
give us blistering legal analysis
they're saying oh no no reasonable
prosecutor would prosecute except if he
names Trump or if you look at Joe Biden
not one not two not three but four
separate locations uh the Biden Penn
Center
Delaware uh the University of Delaware
where he had his car his beach house you
know all with and and again we've yet to
get specifics on what he's had
um amazingly there is a special counsel
in the case of Joe Biden we haven't
heard Ward one from him we have no idea
if any Grand jury's been convened by him
I tend to think not or it would have
leaked or we would have heard something
and and Americans I think are rightly a
lot about what about other
investigations that have a different
timeline participants trajectory and
subject matter what about that
I think that is going to be a view of
many Americans I think what the
Department of Justice is going to say is
that they're charging conduct uh that
shows intent and if you look at the
profile on these uh on these crimes
they're sort of interesting if I was on
the Biden legal team I would be very
uneasy right now to hear that there are
mishandling counts uh Joe Biden
mishandled uh material for a much longer
period in many more locations than did
President Trump so if I was by its
Council I'd be a little bit uneasy and
that's one of the reasons that's going
to be the first thing some of us look to
is how they thread this needle I mean if
if they're charging possession and
retention of possession for a period of
time that would seem to implicate
President Biden but if they carve this
out narrowly to try to focus on specific
acts separate from The Possession then
there's going to be a concern that they
were actually crafting this indictment
not just to go for Donald Trump but to
miss President Biden so those are some
of the things we're going to be looking
at uh because we see what they actually
have here uh but the other problem that
was going to look down the road Sean is
it's going to get very messy you have
the leading candidate for the presidency
of the United States who's in the middle
of a campaign this court is going to be
holding all types of hearings and it's
going to have to make some scheduling
decisions that's going to be one of the
most novel processes we've ever heard of
you know to what extent will the court
yeah I mean there are going to be
logistical issues to overcome so maybe
just like let them get away with the
entire thing I don't know
you know but people forget that the doj
is part of the executive branch this is
Joe Biden's doj this is Joe Biden's AG
you know we we have an ongoing
investigation by Jim Jordan on the house
Judiciary Committee into whether or not
the FBI is weaponized uh or politicized
and the doj is being weaponized yep
we're going to find out about that very
soon the Republicans are going to tell
us whether the doj has been has been
weaponized all right let's let's
these people think we're going to take
them seriously in this on on this stuff
it's just wild wild stuff they caught
the Mark Levin rant on Twitter which is
good because it was completely whacked
really really whacked
um and then let's see if we have
anything else
clay Higgins weighing in president Trump
said he has been summoned to appear at
the federal courthouse in Miami on
Tuesday at 3 P.M this is a perimeter
probe from the oppressors hold our POTUS
has this buckle up one out of 50k know
your Bridges Rock Steady calm that is
all man I just don't understand the
slang that little kids use these days I
I just I just don't really know I just
don't understand much of it
um Espionage Act we mentioned that we
certainly are aware of that
Ted Cruz is now fundraiding fundraising
rating it is sort of a raid fundraising
off of Trump's indictment as well you
can help Ted Cruz fight back by giving
him money which is super exciting Kevin
McCarthy is calling it a dark day for
the United States of America saying it
is unconscionable for a president to
indict the leading candidate opposing
him Joe Biden kept classified documents
for decades remember no evidence Joe
Biden is in any way involved in this I
and every American who believes in the
rule of law stand with President Trump
against this grave Injustice House
Republicans will hold this Brazen
weaponization of power accountable
really wild stuff
really really wild stuff Charlie Kirk
has an idea every Republican running for
president should suspend their campaign
and go to Miami as a show of support if
you don't you are part of the problem
either we have an opposition party or we
don't go to Miami Tuesday and show
solidarity or we will Mark you as part
of the opposition
all right that mean that sounds pretty
interesting to me I would have
absolutely no problem go go go go go go
to Miami make it a make it a total
sideshow
um Dead Eye says via Super Chat forgive
my ignorance what does this mean for
Trump exactly is there something in
place that prevents him from either
taking the nomination or even serving if
elected or will be will there be soon my
understanding is that by law these
indictments do not impact Trump's legal
ability to run for the nomination nor
for president
and it will really be up to voters to
decide
am I off of this is this just not going
to be
for us and we're going to switch to
someone else or are they going to say
it's all unfair it's all trumped up and
we're still going to choose as our
nominee this guy who's now been indicted
twice and potentially will be indicted
again but legally my understanding is
there is not an issue that there is not
an issue
uh that would push Trump out of the race
if uh anybody has a different
perspective by by certainly let me know
but it is not my understanding that that
is the case uh let's listen a little bit
more here as a result of this and as you
said this is about a document case that
documents that he had the right to have
and never I don't think in any of our
lifetime Sean have we ever seen
something like this he is a former
president he is a candidate to be the
next president of the United States and
his opponent in this race has charged
him with a federal crime this is a very
dark day for our country and we the
people need to stand with Donald Trump
tonight all right so we're getting the
sense of the um reaction here from the
right it's unfair stand with Trump
Republicans should rally around and that
is where we are at this point in time
all right this is going to end my
coverage today we are going to have full
coverage of this tomorrow Trump's
scheduled to speak to the Republican
convention in North Carolina on Saturday
will he do that scheduled to speak in
Iowa will he do that I have absolutely
no idea we don't know where this is
going but Trump indicted again indicted
again and we will be back with you on
the podcast tomorrow see you very soon